if you look at my YouTube career I
wasn't super talented there's not a lot
of entertainment on the videos um
they're not coming for my dashing good
looks the only thing I did was I just
kept going most people quit I just kept
going but most people don't have that
stubbornness consistency for anything
like you are what you consistently do if
you eat one chocolate bar you're fine if
you eat a chocolate bar every meal
you're going to be kind of screwed over
tie yourself Worth to the effort you're
putting in on releasing whatever the
thing is like if you're you want to be
great at podcasting if you did a podcast
cast a month how many years does it take
to catch up to 365 it's like it's never
going to happen whatever goals you have
when you take consistent action you're
going to win need motivation watch your
top 10 with believe Nation head s
Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need them from me because I
want to wake up every day and watch a
video that puts me in a mindset to
believe in myself more and go off and
accomplish amazing things and attack the
day and I hope that this video does that
for you as well okay so today let's
learn from one of the best my husband
Evan carmichel and over take on his top
10 rules for Success
enjoy rule number two get more momentum
what are some steps that you think
people should take or can take uh to get
that momentum to add more of that to
their life I think it starts with
identifying where do you lack right like
what do you want to get better at so for
you it's like hey I want to be a better
entrepreneur I don't have business
people in my life so I'm going to make
an effort to be a people who are more
successful at that thing so if you have
a health goal or relationship goal
business goal they don't it's not that
you have to hang on Elon Musk to get it
right I mean there's lots of people
who've done it if if it's a relationship
goal who are the happiest couples that
you know and try to spend more time with
them or health goal who are the people
who are running you know or or just
working out on their own and how do you
spend more time with them when you're in
that Circle you'll just do a lot more so
what is the thing that you are lacking
um and then I would split that between
uh moments like an event or conference
or hanging out with somebody and then
what can you do consistently on The
Daily right so what ends up happening is
you get really motivated you go to a
conference you meet some people you
learn and it takes you to another level
but then it's easy to fall back down to
you know where you were like Oh I
thought I could I thought I could write
a book like I can't write a book I'm not
going to start a show I can't what what
did I think I could do that from because
you've been taken out of the environment
put back into your current environment
so it's harder to to get going again not
impossible just harder but I love those
moments because it shows what's possible
and I'm a big believer that the ideas
that come to you when you're feeling
bold powerful confident courageous are
actually the right ones for you like
those are your best ideas and then your
head talks you down from doing them
because it doesn't it only understands a
world that currently exists like well
you didn't go to school for this what
you're going to be an entrepreneur you
can't be an entrepreneur right like the
head starts to take over so those ideas
that came to you when you're at that
conference you're around these people
like those are actually the right ones
for you and you need to then inject new
things daily to remind yourself of the
person you want to be so that's why I
have things like my YouTube channel
right because I need a daily because I
want to be around uh I want to be around
Oprah Winfrey and Steve Jobs and Elon
Musk and Bill Gates and these people
every day that when I'm watching their
video it makes me want to go and do more
rule number three make an impact what do
you think is the best part about being
an entrepreneur and what's the scariest
part if you had the kind of worn would
be entrepreneurs out
there I think the reason you get into
entrepreneurship uh has to has to be
strong that you're moving towards
something not away from something hating
your job is not a good enough reason uh
having a bad boss is not a good enough
reason having toxic people around you in
your workplace means you should get out
of that but that's not the reason that
go be an entrepreneur because you're
gonna work harder as an entrepreneur
than you will
yes that's job right now now you're you
get yes you get to set the rules and you
get to decide what you want to do but if
if you're only in it because of Freedom
that's the wrong reason you have to be
in it because you want to make an impact
you have to want to serve I I believe
that humans are built to serve I think
it's in all of us I think it's hardwired
into into us uh and that how do you
serve well your purpose comes from your
pain that the thing that you struggled
with the most in life whatever the most
painful moment of your life was
helping other people not go through the
same thing that you went through will be
the thing that will fill you up for life
and will never get old and so that's the
thing that people need to find I love
helping entrepreneurs because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur so
I want to I want to now pay it forward
and help others and that's that's
everybody so you need to figure out
what's the what's the going to that
you're you're creating not the moving
away from and then how you're going to
serve and if you if you do that you'll
have success I think most entrepreneurs
when they get started they're doing it
for the wrong reasons because they just
don't like their job and then they're
just chasing an
opportunity they don't actually love the
thing but this is a hot thing to do in
2019 2020 2021 so that's what I'm going
to do but if you don't love that thing
you're going to lose um so that's the
biggest mistake most entrepreneurs made
rule number four anticipate a hard start
what advice would you give to this
person to kind of I don't know if it's
like to shake things up in their world
or just to give them momentum wow so
there's a lot there uh I would want to
know more about the individual but some
generic advice one I would expect to
suck at the start I would expect a
struggle at the start I think people
expect to be amazing at the start and
then they're shocked by how hard it is
when they actually get out and go uh
certainly my case I expected to be doing
way better than I I was at the beginning
and I was actually too embarrassed to
tell my friends and too ashamed that
like I was making no money and I
couldn't come out to dinner or birthday
parties not because I was too busy but
because that 20 bucks was too much for
me to go out for a night so expect to
suck at the start um I think remembering
your why remembering what you're doing
remember the big ambition that you have
I think if you started a business just
to try to make money you will fail
because it's going to get hard and it's
a deep passion for what you do that
helps you through those tough times that
you would keep doing it even if you
weren't making any money because you
just love it soone it's it's a part of
you what what this is is a part of you
you have to keep doing it if you stop it
a piece of you dies you like that's what
you need to find and so making money is
important too but it's never number one
there's got to be something more
important if you only did it to make
money you're going to fail also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five overcome your
fears perfectionism is really just fear
you know you're just afraid right so I
try I mean of course I'm still afraid of
many things but if I can catch it I try
not to be or do the thing that makes me
scared but to the Kill Your Darlings um
yeah one of my greatest fears earlier on
uh in my career
was being an aan rock star and so one of
the things that for some reason really
bothered me was you look at these rock
stars who were big in like the 70s or
80s or 90s or whatever and they still go
on tour and like wow they're still on
tour like it's amazing that they're
still on but they're still singing the
songs they were singing like decades ago
yes you know like where is the new stuff
like have you had nothing new to say in
30 years since you recorded the thing
right and right anytime you're anytime
you're uh judgmental of somebody else
it's self-reflection it's like it's your
own your word about yourself not about
like Aeros Smith or whatever doesn't
care about me or my opinion and I don't
really hate on Aeros so it's like if you
are criticizing somebody else it's like
well look inside cuz you have that same
thing that you're criticizing and I
realized it was my fear that I I don't
want to be that like I don't want to be
Evan uh you know 30 years later still
making videos yay but like telling the
war stories of back in 2023 when you
know was Sean talking about Tom Brady uh
I want to make new stuff right I want to
make new stuff and and I think I've I've
overcome that one um I only bring up the
past when people ask me questions about
um about the past uh but that was yeah
that was a big thing that was a big fear
of mine early on getting started it's
like I didn't want to just hold on to my
darlings and sing the same songs over
and over and over again rule number six
make a better choice the more that you
can make choices
that build self-respect and build
character the more you're capable of
making more choices like that people
think of it as some giant thing like
whatever your goals are I talk to a lot
of entrepreneurs so they want to start
their business but whatever your goals
are your personal your health goals your
Fitness your relationship your business
goals whatever they are it's not just
some one thing one giant goal that you
chase it's the daily minor decisions
that you have to make it's every day you
have this choice to am I going to do the
thing I said I was going to do or am I
going to not do it you know like am I
going to let myself down again here or
am I going to do the thing that makes me
proud and it's in in these minor
decisions that we have every day that
ultimately leads to you building your
character so I when you started your
show it's great amazing a lot of people
would love to start a show like you did
a lot of people would love to have
guests on their show as well and they'
immediately have that insecurity in
their head come to say well who's going
to listen to me and what am I going to
talk about and which guest is going to
want to come on my show and they've been
on other shows how am I better how am I
different and my show and they've been
different and what that does is shut
down your action to go and create the
show and the more you listen to that
voice the the less action you do and the
more you teach yourself that you suck do
it you're training yourself to not do it
again the next time and not doing it
because this becomes your identity like
I'm the person who has great ideas but
never follows through and that is
something that we have to start to
consciously destroy on the health
Journey well I'm just a fat person and I
can't stick to a diet and I can't do
anything I can't run more than a mile I
can't like and we've created this
identity but all of those things are
fixable but it's not one giant leap
right you don't just get healthy by
going to the gym one day it's the
everyday consistency that you train
yourself for rule number seven monetize
your passion I'm writing a new book
about finding your purpose and turn into
a business and then I included the last
chapter on how to make money because I
think a lot of people feel icky
or nasty about trying to well I just
love helping these people so I can't
charge for this I think it actually is
selfish not to charge for it I think it
becomes your your obligation that you
have to charge for it not to everybody I
think you they'll always be a percentage
if it's 10% or 20% of people who who get
in for free because they can't afford it
but
if you don't learn how to make money
from your purpose then it will always be
a hobby and you'll always have to do a
full-time job to then support your hobby
where if you actually made it a business
and learned how to make money us doing
it serving people in an ethical you know
life-changing positive way then you can
reach more people you can build a team
you can scale up now instead of as maybe
as a hobby you can hit 10 women a month
wow hobby but if you have a business and
now you're you're building a team of
amazing women who all want the same
thing maybe now you're reaching millions
of women W so I think it I think it's
your responsibility to to turn that into
something that then can create a ripple
effect greater than just a hobby on the
side rule number eight learn from others
how you can model success this is what
saved my business when I wanted to quit
at my company my first software company
and then I realized Iz that you know
what I'm not the first guy to try to
sell software before like somebody has
figured this
out if I just learn from that person I
can apply those strategies to my
business and so I modeled Bill Gates who
started Microsoft and I've never met
Bill Gates but he saved my company and I
looked at the strategies of how did he
start Microsoft not how does Microsoft
grow now who cares it's a huge company
but like start how did he start zero to
one that's what I wanted to do and I
modeled him and I applied that to my
business and we started to grow
and so whatever dreams whatever goals
whatever business you have somebody's
already figured it out may not be
exactly what you want to do and that's
good because you're different you're an
entrepreneur you're gonna put your own
twist on it but people have already
figured it out and so understanding what
they did and trying to break down their
success could be really helpful so that
if you're hustling and grinding you're
spending your time on the right things
that will help you as opposed to the
things that aren't leading to
success so so when you say model after
them you you mean like you don't
necessarily have to meet this person you
can just read their books or watch their
interviews is that how you learned from
from Bill Gates for example yeah so
there's two kinds of mentors there's the
regular mentors that people think about
where you go for coffee and they're you
know they're local you can go meet them
and they break down your business uh and
I never had that right like my parents
taught me so much about life and being a
human being but never about business and
nobody in my family was an entrepreneur
and so I had nobody to go and have
coffee with I went to my banker and said
hey can you help me with my business and
like well do you need a loan like no I
don't know do I need a loan I don't know
he's like yeah you're not really in the
right place like I didn't know anybody
and so I Look To What I Call
aspirational mentors these the people
who you aspire to be like or aspire to
learn from and some people may have
already passed on and you'll never meet
them like I have Steve Jobs up on my
wall I'm never going to meet him
obviously um and a lot of people behind
me uh some I may meet one day or some
have passed on uh and so I would look at
two kinds of what I aspirational mentors
the first are in your industry whatever
you want to do somebody has done it you
want to be a successful YouTuber there's
lots of people who've done it Go and
model them see what they did the more uh
successful they are the more information
there is on them whether it's interviews
or books or magazine articles like their
story is somewhere and again look to how
they got started as opposed to what
they're doing now because it's a
different scale and then the second kind
are just the people who you look up to
you know if if I love Oprah Winfrey I
could learn something from her even if I
don't want to have my own talk show you
know if you love Michael Jordan you
could learn from him even if you never
want to be a basketball player like the
way that he works and his hustle and
effort he's in the gym you can apply
that to your life and to your business
even if you never go on to try to become
an NBA player so those two things the
people who have done what you want to do
maybe you hate them but you can still
learn from their success right and just
do it your way and then the people you
just really look up to and really admire
and say one day I want to have that kind
of impact again understanding how they
got started and modeling their success
to help you get your breakthrough rule
number nine change your environment I
think everybody can can lean in and
learn whatever they want to learn um I
had the Good Fortune of having some
great parents on the they're on the wall
behind me here I'm eight or nine years
old and those are my parents there and
they would always tell me hey you're EV
car Micha like you do anything you
believe that you can and so they helped
instill that in me um I think the whole
you know the Gary Vee's point about are
you born with it well what were you
doing at 7 years old like were you doing
lemonade stains and garage sales and
taking some initiative um but if you
weren't don't feel like oh my gosh now I
can't be an entrepreneur it's it's so
much easier now than ever to start your
own business or to lean in on the thing
for sure like I believe everybody's got
Michael Jordan level genius at something
like you're the greatest in the world at
something
and you just don't believe that you are
and you don't believe in your dreams
enough to go chase them down but you can
whether it's being an entrepreneur and
believe in your business whether it's
believing in your health Journey that
it's possible whether it's you know
climbing Mount kilero or losing 100
pounds or like whatever the thing is
that you'd love to do it's it's possible
people like you have done it and that's
where a lot of people get stuck is like
well it's possible like somebody else
has done it but I can't do it because
I'm whatever and my story early with the
YouTube stuff was um I'm an introvert
I'm shy so I'm I'm not going to make it
you know but I'll keep making content
because I'm serving but I'm I'm never
going to be the big name because I'm too
introverted and too shy and I still am
by the way it just doesn't come out when
I'm doing shows like this um but you can
you know you can whatever whatever that
story is in your head it's totally
fixable and other people you know like
you have done it and it just comes down
down to starting to change what you put
into your head I think that's the
biggest thing of all that's why I make
so much content
because if somebody felt like their
health Journey was impossible you know
it's like you know Jay you don't
understand I was impossible you know
understand I've been like this and my
family's been like this and it's just
not possible and I've tried a million
things and just nothing works and it's
it's never going to happen Jay this
that's that's who I am right if they
spend
a month with you you know because you're
more confident in their ability to get
healthy than they are in their inability
to get
healthy and same thing with me if
somebody's hanging out with me for an
extented period of time if we were
hanging out together uh I'm going to get
a lot healthier
probably and you're going to be making
more YouTube videos man we're going to
get you on there and and crushing it
because whoever is more confident wins
and so the problem is we're surrounded
by people who don't believe in our
dreams who tell us that it's not
possible and we're also feeding our mind
with things that keep us stuck where we
are and if you want to change something
it's totally possible but it starts with
actually changing um that environment so
that you have a you have the crutch like
to get going to get you out of the
Starting Gate rule number 10 before some
special bonus clip explore you feel like
some people are just that entrepreneurs
are
born I know you say that everybody has
it enough to serve but you think there's
some people that are just more prone or
um more gifted or more capable when it
comes to um achieving
entrepreneurship so I think I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level Talent at something okay uh if you
go religious you know everybody's a
child of God you were created you
beautiful you should be making something
amazing in the world you are not meant
to be living this small life right so if
everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something for some people
that's being an entrepreneur for others
it might be being a teacher in the
school right it could be many things how
do you find it well you need to
explore you need to taste you need to
test you know just like you found my
videos you were searching for motivation
and you found them and then you you like
I like this then you do into it a lot of
times you can't think your way through
these things because chances are the
thing that you should be doing is very
different than what is in your family
and in your circle most of the time the
thing that you should be doing with life
is very different than what your parents
did or what your brothers or sisters or
cousins or Community or church people
that are doing yeah and so it takes
courage to go off and do it right if if
you're if you're working with women who
have a belief system of well women are
supposed to be this way but then they
know that like I don't want to be that
I'm I'm greater than that I know I'm
greater than that right yeah to have the
courage to chase that dream down I think
is important and that's where I think
people like you or a
voice
do you think that for people who are
looking at making an impact whether that
be online or through content or speaking
or any of those different Avenues where
do you see that kind of the next Horizon
kind of like you entered YouTube very
early on what do you think's next so I
think it depends on what your mission is
right so for me I've got a giant mission
right I want to impact the whole world
and so how do you do that well my
hypothesis is that it's content at scale
and if you're going to do content at
scale you've got two options long form
or short form like the platforms are
basically
divided Tik Tok and snap and Facebook
and Instagram are all short form content
and then YouTube is long form and
YouTube has shorts I guess as a
combination but there's YouTube on one
side with the long form and all the
other content which is short form and if
if you want to have an impact and really
want to make a difference I I think it's
hard to do it in 30C little Clips so
that's a lot more inspiring but it's not
really making a huge impact if you're
trying to explain multif family
investing in a 42 second video like good
luck right so so but it's fine like the
shorts have their own path it's to
inspire but it's not really to to do
deep education and you're not really
doing any of the deep work just from the
clip so hopefully clipse Inspire
somebody to start down the path to learn
more about this thing how can people out
there you know discover for themselves
when to actually make that call to let
go as someone who wants to make things
like happen and make them a success how
do you know when to actually let go of
something you let go when you don't love
it
anymore a business a relationship if you
don't love it you should let go as soon
as possible um and most most people fall
into Zoo camps
one they quit too soon they still love
it this I see a lot of entrepreneurs
they they still love their business but
it's not working out and so they quit on
it this is why I went back to my
business because I still loved it if you
quit on it too soon and you still love
it you're going to regret that your
whole life yeah you're going to 10 years
20 years 40 years whatever you're going
to look back and say I could have I
could have done a little more you know I
could I quit too soon and so if you
still love it but it has worked out yet
you have to keep going otherwise you're
going to regret it and use that as fuel
the flip side is a lot of people who
stay in the thing for too long when
they're when they sto loving it yeah
people stay in relationships too long
when they stopped loving it they stay in
businesses for too long when they
stopped loving it because they've had
some success with it you're not going to
see in a crappy business forever if the
business has taken off but then you stop
loving it and you feel like you bought
yourself a job when you quit ASAP yeah
like sell it to somebody else and move
on cuz you're never going to win doing
work that you hate yeah so while you
still have one foot in the pool of like
it's just okay I don't hate it I don't
love it can you tweak it so that you
can't love it or is it time to move on
and go do something else
um this is what I do on the micro and
the macro always um I still love making
YouTube videos I'm I'm 6,000 videos in
10 years I still love it but the day
that I stopped liking making videos if I
have to go to my camera be like I'm I
don't know I'm not feeling it that's it
I
done yeah done like I I'll say hey you
want to take with my YouTube channel you
know try to sell it move on or something
else cuz I'm never going to win doing
work that I hate and that's a big
decision and you're just getting started
in all of this right yes the opportunity
here
is there's the big long-term opportunity
of you could help whether it's everybody
whether it's women whether it's wom of
color or whatever that's there's a lot
of people in in even just North America
who need that that yeah the immediate
opportunity is figuring out okay how do
we how do we replace our salary correct
because the the women on the train may
not be able to afford you as a coach
right so this is where a lot of people
get stuck at the beginning say I love
these people and they're so good my want
to help and then you get you get pulled
into either helping them for free or
doing it like super discounted rate and
you feel so fulfilling but it's like you
are not making money right so it's it's
just an order of sequencing so it's not
that you'll you're not able to help
those women in a deep way it's just not
now right because now is we need to
prioritize within our mission making
money yeah so that we can afford to quit
our job and then make more money so we
can afford to hire team to help us build
our brain so like I'm purpose first yes
you have to learn how to monetize right
right like number one is Mission purpose
and then somewhere in two to five has to
be making money right if an entrepreneur
or you don't make money I encourage
entrepreneurs to go through um a
three-step process which is eliminate
automate delegate okay so you look at
the work that you're doing and maybe you
shouldn't be doing it at all like before
you give it to somebody else maybe it
just shouldn't get done and there
there's often things that we're doing
that we think are really high value that
then turn out to like to not matter and
we may not even notice it right I mean
before Movie Makers I had a mastermind
that I ran in Toronto for entrepreneurs
and when people joined um we took uh
minutes like notes of what was happening
like I took minutes this before AI could
do it for you and transcripts like I
wrote down minutes for what everybody
said and homework and assignments and
everything and um there was one month
where I forget what happened like I was
going away the next day or something and
I didn't get the notes out to people
after the meeting nobody
cared like no response no message no
like Hey where's the minutes where's the
notes and I and so I didn't do it again
next month nobody cared it's like wow
I've been spending all this time on
something that like nobody cared about
that I thought was high value but was
actually zero value for people um maybe
it was even negative value maybe I was
annoying them with it I don't know uh
and so eliminate first you know so I
mean a lot of entrepreneurs might be
frustrated with their accounting and
bookkeeping uh you cannot eliminate that
right like that has to get done yeah you
will run into problems if you try to
eliminate that from your business right
and I was going to go into that for you
but yeah keep going yeah the government
will come for you that is a big problem
unless you live in some country that
that doesn't move to the moon or
something but um yeah you know that's a
problem so you can't eliminate that but
but there's a lot of things that we're
doing that just should not be done they
just be completely eliminated the next
is automate so before giving it to a
human give it to technology so use
software use tools use AI use QuickBooks
use like there's a lot of things there's
software and tools for a lot of things
that you should should start applying
into your
business uh that can save a lot of manh
hours um and then you get to delegate so
eliminate automate and then delegate and
so these are the things that still have
to get done but should not be done by
you so in eliminate they shouldn't be
done at all in automate they need to be
done but should be done by a human
and then in delegate it's it it should
be done but shouldn't be done by you has
to be done by another human and that's
where you start to scale and build and
create you were making 80 videos in one
day you know so you can do uh basically
all the videos for a month in one day um
do one do you still do that and two um
what's the logic behind that and where
do you find the time management for
something like that because that's one
of my uh one of my big downfalls I'm not
so good with time management that's
something I'm learning
myself yeah
so I don't do 80 a day anymore that was
when I was filming once a month I film
once a week now and so we'll cut that
back to 20ish videos a week um more
because I'm spending more time on each
of the videos and my team is preparing
things for me that that we're not a
month ahead on uh for the time
management it's
just your your actions need to map to
your Ambitions and so you have ambitions
and not just business Ambitions life
Ambitions like I don't know if you're
married or not or kids or not or but
whatever your life Ambitions are then I
I default to looking at my calendar and
I say okay I look at my week next week
if I did the things that are in my
calendar for next week am I moving
closer to hitting my ambitions or not so
if I'm if I'm making videos then yeah
but if I spend a week and there's no
videos happening then no I'm not I'm not
getting closer to my ambitions and so if
you think that your time management is
isue now you know it only gets harder as
you grow bigger like if you I have 24
people on my team it's harder you know
like I gotta manage all these people on
top of managing myself uh and so one I
remind myself of whatever I'm doing
right now whatever challenge I think
that's in front of me I tell myself this
is just a warmup like this is just a
warmup I'm capable of of more I'm
capable of more than what I'm facing
right now because if feel like the
current problem is overwhelming then
that's the limit of what you're capable
of doing so this is just a warm up
then I look at uh I look at my calendar
and I look at my goals and I see how do
I how do I match these things up uh I'm
a I'm a huge believer and this may not
work for you but I chunk my days so
Thursday is my public facing day you
know we're talking on Thursday I don't
know when you guys are gonna launch this
thing but I'm an introvert and so that
may not come across you may not believe
me but I am and and I need to get up for
for public I call this public facing day
so I need to to get up for my interviews
and it's been all day interviews and
podcasts and hangouts and and meetups
and that's my Thursday every day and I
like that because I have a really hard
time switching tasks like to talk to you
guys and be all fired up and energetic
and then go and write my book and then
come back and then do another interview
like I I can't the energy level it's
doable but it just sucks so much for me
that it's better for me to s one zone
for the day I find it super helpful
whatever you want to sell show me the
process of you doing it so if you don't
have an email list yet you can even look
at who's following you on Instagram and
message people and say hey I'm I'm gonna
do a free coaching session for people
who wants 25 minutes of my time for free
to talk about coaching whatever issue
you have you're an entrepreneur whatever
confidence issue you're facing right now
I will Coach you for free but it's going
to be online okay those are two
different shows though the biz Dev show
is we're trying to build a relationship
with a potential clent and get them on
the show to tell their story but then
inject a little bit of what you do 25%
of the show is about you and confidence
coaching helping them the second show is
just a straightup coaching show where
they know they're coming on to be coach
but they may not be they may not be an
ideal client for you it's just anybody
who needs coaching okay okay because I
need I I want to see that you're a good
coach because you can talk and you can
give me your framework XYZ and you can
you can have all your material you can
but that makes you a good
speaker how do I know if you're a good
coach right like Ted Williams was a
great baseball player but he wasn't a
great coach so you could be a great
speaker it doesn't mean you're good
coach so how do I know if you're good
coach I need to see you coach so you
that's a that's a separate series on the
channel so now we're splitting it up
between the BISD show where we're trying
to get clients and a coaching show where
we're we don't care if their ideal
clients are not coming on We're just
trying to show coaching and and help
them of course and help them and then if
you have your website or you build out
your funnel that then becomes content so
when somebody lands on your hey hire
Frankie to be your coach I can see
examples of what you do and how you
coach people is there a habit that you
formed that helped you that helps you
break through that introversion and make
those videos every single
day uh so yes so one default in the
service so I remember I was I was uh
late last year I was speaking in front
of a couple thousand people in Phoenix
and I I blanked out 10 minutes before
going on stage I blanked out I forgot
what I was gonna say and in my head like
oh my God Brendan bashard and N gratos
invited me to come and speak at their
event and I'm speaking after Eric Thomas
and and I'm I'm blanking I just imagine
myself getting on stage and having a
meltdown and just letting everybody down
and and what I did was I I peaked from
backstage to the audience and reminded
myself it's not even about me it's about
them like I'm here for them stop being
so selfish get out of your way you've
got knowledge I can help them and go out
there and serve and so the serving gives
me the strength to overcome the the
anxiety and stress plus I built an
identity around if I say scary difficult
or hard that means I have to do it talk
to me a little bit about the service
mentality and that service above self
mentality that I mentioned because I
feel like it's really um a part of your
core it's something that you really
really
authenticate so I haven't heard of uh
service above self before but I'm also
not part of rotary and um I think
ultimately service is the path to
self I think I think humans are built to
serve I think if you're not happy it's
because you're not
serving every day we all want to wake up
and feel like what we we do matters to
somebody else we want to feel like the
job we're going to or the business we're
creating or whatever we're going to do
today is going to have an impact on
somebody else and some people you and I
and probably most of your listeners we
want to change the world we want to have
a big impact we want to go and you know
have our message reach wide and far but
not because of us but because of the
impact that we want to create and other
people like my wife
Nina she doesn't want to have a big
mission but she serves the 25 closest
people to us she's the glue for our
family remember everybody's birthdays
and what they're doing and what they
need and what they're going through and
all of the stuff that I
forget and probably I should get better
at but everybody wants to serve serving
others is hardwired into our brain they
did functional MRIs on people's brains
and found that serving other people hits
the same part of your brain as having
food and having sex so it's like
literally hardwired into your brain that
you need this to be a functioning happy
member of society I think some people um
have experience things like act of
kindness you know how nice it is to buy
the coffee with a person behind you in
line or hold the door or those kinds of
things and those moments are great and
keep doing them but I think everybody
also has a much deeper level of service
where I believe that your purpose comes
from your pain that whatever you
struggled the most with as a human is
what you want to help other people
through and so when you can see somebody
who is going through the thing that you
went through and feels hopeless and lost
and is struggling and doesn't see a way
out and then they spend eight minutes
with you you say hey you know what it's
okay it's like I went through that too
and here's how to get out and then you
see hope in their eyes for the first
time and like you made that happen you
caused that and then that's that little
that's a that's a spark in their life
that can change the entire trajectory of
their life life that's the thing to get
addicted to like that's what we all want
and I think we're living in a world now
where a lot of people find zero meaning
in their work they're driving to a job
that they hate and I'm just trying to
ignite some passion in people what your
current morning routine looks like so I
go through five s's uh sing Sun sore
sweat scare so sing I put on music right
away and any song that will get you like
if it came on you'd have to bounce and
you'd have to sing right yeah um so
right now there's a there's a Chinese
rap that I did it's a Chinese song that
I did a rap in English on top of yeah
and so I play that every morning um
Chinese rap is like dance or is it like
straight up like hardcore rap uh I'm
rapping yeah to a Chinese song so it's
this woman who's rapping and I sped her
up and then I'm rapping over the parts
where she's not singing it was a fun
little project that I worked on um so I
like it it makes me move so I I'm
rapping to my own song song every
morning while it comes on but whatever
song gets you up and ready to go cuz we
wake up and you know you're tired and
starting your day and so music is the
fastest way to change your state like as
soon as it comes on in 5 seconds you can
already be feeling better right oh yeah
and there's no one Magical song it's
whatever it is for you and the audience
um then Sun so I like to get outside so
we got two dogs are in here with us
today I like to get outside outside just
to get some fresh air on my face we're
in Toronto it's December there's not a
lot of sun happening right now but just
just getting out of your environment
even if you work from home the the walk
from just your bedroom to the office you
can carry with that still the tired
energy of the bedroom right so get
outside get some fresh air even if it's
um just go out on the balcony and just
take in some sun for a little bit mother
nature mother nature makes a difference
um then soar so this is the most
important part what is the thing that
you need to do every day that makes you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable confident
alive whatever that thing is do it first
thing in the morning instead of waiting
like maybe it's listening to the pav
your Paradise podcast or watching the
video series now it's happening if
that's a thing then then you watch it
every morning you listen to it every
morning um most of us don't have enough
intention behind the day yeah and so I
know it's part of what you do in the
morning too but for me it's uh I go live
on Instagram so service if I feel like
the work that I'm doing matters is
important I'm serving somebody it it
makes me more amped up for the day
totally so I'll go live on Instagram
every morning and people join in from
around the world asking questions and I
help them and quick half hour um and
that's what I need to do so other people
maybe it's meditation maybe it's prayer
maybe it's something like anything
whatever the thing is that makes you
feel bold powerful confident if you
started your day with the thing that
made you feel bold and Powerful your
your year is going to look totally
different like where you are in one year
will be totally different than where you
are right now amen um and then the last
two are just sweat and Scar so I'll do a
workout and then hop into a cold shower
cuz like what do you like to do for
working out
um usually do 100 push-ups 100 squats
what am I doing now 100 push-ups 100
squats and 100 jumping jacks yeah and
then you do like the Wim Hof the whole
like cold hot that's it uh not hot just
cold just cold just cold yeah there's no
hot in the Wim Hof no no I mean like the
cold like the whole the the Heat and
coolness like you get really worked out
like sweaty and then you do the cold
then jump into the cold yeah what you
believe about yourself is the only thing
that matters at the end of the day no
matter how much outside affirmation you
get or other people telling you that
you're amazing if you don't believe in
your heart that you are amazing none of
that will last like if you ever going to
an event or you ever made a video or
created something or you're hanging out
with a friend and they tell you how
amazing you are and that feels good but
then it fades that that stuff doesn't
last you don't have somebody being a
cheerleader for you every day showing up
in your bedroom saying hooray go do this
you're amazing right we don't have that
you have to be that for yourself if
you're constantly only getting your
value as a human being from other people
when they tell you that you're amazing
you're never going to love your life
you're never going to love yourself it
has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing I think for me this
is why I believe that lack of belief is
the world's number one problem you know
I can go and meet somebody and feel them
full of belief for a moment but if they
still don't believe in themselves and
they're going home back to a life that
they they had before because they don't
believe in themselves enough and so you
have to design habits and routines and
systems and schedules to slowly shift
your belief in yourself forward every
single day everybody has an off day but
it seems like you never do and I think
that and I'm sure you still do but when
you're on in front of the camera you're
doing it for the viewers you know what I
mean you're you're putting your selfish
you know bad day I guess aside and
you're focusing on the product and I
think that's awesome and that's really
attractive to me as a viewer that you're
willing to put in the commitment to spit
out three videos a day you know what I
mean yeah you know I uh I suffocate
negativity in my life it happens you
know maybe my wife isn't happy in the
morning or maybe someone on my team is
is pissed off when they started the day
or whatever my natural reaction is one
to like try to avoid that situation
right for that time and then just I just
get so excited I don't know my default
is if there's negativity in my life I
need to suffocate it not give it any
oxygen and go the other way I don't know
where that comes from
but it's not hard to get up for it's not
hard to get up for this like I'm talking
a dick I'm pumped let's do it you know
even if something crappy happened just
before it doesn't matter I'm ready to go
when I'm making the videos for the
channel it's the same thing like it's
easy to get it's least it's easy for me
to get all excited about it because
again it's tied into the work that I do
and and why I know the why of what I do
try to help entrepreneurs I believe
entrepreneurs are going to solve all the
major world problems not not
corporations and not you know not Banks
and not government it's entrepreneurs
and so if my
work uh adds a little bit half a percent
to make the difference for dick or
whoever to go out and push a little bit
harder that's meaningful to me and so I
try to take that with me when I'm going
into filming day um absolutely and just
suffocate like you have to you have to
suffocate negativity out to focus I
think if you're trying to get your
journey going on YouTube cool take a
bite and see try making videos try doing
Vlogs try doing interviews try doing
direct the camera try doing speeches try
the things that you see and expect to
suck at all of them at the beginning
you're not going to be good because you
don't have the skill set yet doesn't
mean you suck as a human you just you
don't have the skill set yet but the
thing to pay attention to is did you
enjoy it how did you feel after doing it
you had that interview and it's easy to
go back if you go back and watch your
first interview it's a train wack it
mean you're awkward and nervous and ask
the wrong questions and you can look
back on it and say oh my gosh I should
have done that and you can go go over it
in your head a million times but like
but did you like it you know like was it
fun to do do you want to go back and do
it again did it give you more energy
than it took and if it's a yes then
that's a great sign to keep
going and so a lot of people stop on
YouTube because they don't get immediate
results because they're not doing
something that they feels authentic to
them um and they're focused on who
they're not serving instead of who they
are serving um and they just judge
themselves too harshly for not having a
skill set yet like you don't just get on
a snowboard and go down the hill you
fall 80 times on your first run and then
you fall 50 times on your second run
right and you just you get better as you
go most entrepreneurs aren't patient
enough most entrepreneurs end up losing
their business they end up shutting down
because they think it's going to happen
in a couple months or even 6 months or a
year and really it's going to take them
four years 5 years before they hit their
Mark they don't have enough patience
they don't allow enough time for
momentum to build up and they quit and
they end up going back to a crappy job
job that they hate and maybe never ever
take a shot to get an entrepreneurship
because they feel it's not for them or
really they missed out you missed out on
your destiny you missed on Crea
something amazing because you just
didn't have enough patience now I
believe in patience in the macro I
believe in patience and knowing it's
going to take a long time I also think
impatience can serve you greatly but
that's in the micro that's in the daily
the impatience of did I do my best today
did I do my best today can I do better
can I drive more can I drive harder and
knowing that even if I give my best
every single day it's still going to
take time it's still going to take a
number of years for something to happen
I want it to happen as soon as possible
I'm going to drive and being impatient
as crazy to get it going but I know it's
going to take time too it's embracing
both that's when you start to win I look
at my my YouTube my Instagram my social
media strategy YouTube 7,000 subscribers
4 years ago 1.2 million subscribers now
4 years by making videos every day every
day and I'm impatient as anything
because I want it to be amazing I want
to make every video better than the last
and looking for all the hacks and SEO
and thumbnail strategies and title
strategies and all of the stuff that
we're supposed to do right I'm on top of
it and I know that it's going to take me
4 years to get there I know it's going
to take me while to get to my next 2
million 5 million 10 million I look at
Instagram follow me on my Instagram
Journey I'm starting from nothing you
can see how to build it up from zero I
had 8,00 followers many of you already
have more followers than I do on
Instagram but I'm going to win I'm going
to pass people I'm going to get mine
because I'm going to make daily
consistent content three to four times a
day for 4 years I'm going to be
impatient as anything and that the post
today has to be amazing has to be
something that I want to show my
grandkids right that's the intent every
time I create anything I want my
grandkids to watch this video I want my
grandkids to watch the next Instagram
thing that I put up it's the best that I
can come up with in the moment and I
know it's going to take me 4 years maybe
3 years maybe 2 years but it's not going
to take me 2
months I realized it's going to take
working hard and working smart together
always because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a #
believe down in the comments Below on
this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
if you want to watch Tom Bilo's top 10
rules for Success check out the video
next to me I think you're going to enjoy
continue to believe I will see you there
the reason reason that I've had the kind
of success that I've had in my life is
simply because I understand that
iteration is how we make cultural
progress it's what I call the physics of
progress